but what are people getting wrong about
this when we see
uh you know the the the bombing of
palestine when we see
um children being harmed and we uh
see that palestinians are unable to
access medical supplies or
clean water or things like that what
about that or
are we not kind of what are we missing
so i think two things one is history and
the second is
really the aperture of the lens that
you're using to look at the conflict
with
so let's start with the second thing
which is if you're looking at the
israeli-palestinian conflict like this
you're going to see exactly to some
extent him what you just described
you're going to see
israel as the goliath it has the
military power etc
and you're going to see palestinians as
having the the less strong hand
but if you widen out and zoom out with
your lens
what you're going to see is an entire
region
filled with something like 22 arab and
muslim nations
and a jewish state the only jewish state
in the world
that is smaller than than new jersey
that state surrounded on all sides um
the abraham accords aside and we can get
into that
by people that don't seek its
borders to be shifted but that
fundamentally seek its destruction
i think the thing that people
fundamentally get wrong
is that they think that this is a
conflict fundamentally about borders
it is not a conflict about borders it is
a conflict about whether or not
israel has a right to exist it is a
conflict
about zionism and anti-zionism it's a
conflict about
whether jews like every other people has
a right to self-determination
in this case in their native land or
whether or not they don't
that is what the conflict is about
whether or not jews can have
any presence in the region of the middle
east at all
that's what this conflict is about and
so to go back kind of to
you know to to go back and watch the
abbey martin clip and of course i you
know defend her sacred right to
say that 911 was an inside job and
everything else that she says but
well there's a lot about 911 we don't
know whether it's an inside job or not i
mean it's not there's a lot we don't
know
we covered for saudi arabia for years we
really then we
said we released a 9 11 commission
report the people on the 911 commission
reports that it was set up to fail
i mean these are direct quotes so i mean
it's not i understand that
no one's saying jews did 911 or whatever
i know some people are
some people are some people are but
there's a lot we don't know there's a
lot we weren't dealt with honestly about
911 we went and attacked iraq you know
so okay well okay that was a throwaway
line
i understand what you mean like yeah
what i meant to say is that
you know everyone has the right to their
own positions but
i'm not gonna sit here and listen while
people
spew lies and right and there's a giant
lie that's being told right now about
israel and it has
incredible power right now especially on
the far left
and that lie goes like this the jews are
white people they are ethnocolonialist
nationalists
who dropped into a foreign exotic land
with which they have no connection and
since 1948 when they plopped into this
land
they have systematically taken that land
from the indigenous brown population of
palestinians
and indeed more than that they're
bloodthirsty
they're warmongers and they won't stop
until they've
you know immiserated the people around
them and the problem with this is that
absolutely none of it is true it is a
fantasy projection
created by people with small brains who
have an attention span the length of a
tick-tock video
you know the jews aren't let's start
with the jews aren't white
the jews are from the middle east the
jews
go back to the middle east for three
thousand years
that is the reality the jewish people
precedes the modern conceptions that we
have
of race and of religion okay they were a
tribe they were the judeans they were
the judaized living in judea
and the jewish presence in what we now
call the land of israel or the palestine
that goes back all the way back to
that period way before jesus was ever
around the jews themselves were
colonized speaking of colonization
they were colonized by the romans they
were colonized by the byzantines they
were colonized by the crusaders by the
ottomans
and finally by the british and you know
just to
give people a little bit of historical
perspective what is palestine what is
that name
the romans renamed the region syria
palestina
after the philistines to kind of give a
middle finger to the jews that they had
pushed out
as a way of punishing the jews because
the philistines were their mortal enemy
so it's like
you know when israel sort of
miraculously and i think this is what
makes it such a hard story for people to
understand
most indigenous populations are screwed
over
they never get a chance to return to
their land but israel got that chance
after the holocaust in 1948 1947 1948
and basically the u.n comes to the
jewish people
and says we are and the arabs living in
the region
and says here is the partition plan
essentially the jews get half the
muslims get half and not the muslims the
jews get half the arabs get half
and the jews said great and their
motivation for saying great was
they weren't going to get anything else
and in totally real politic terms it
makes sense that the palestinians said
no
but then they said no again after every
single offer
to split the land and and i think that
that is really
what it's about in the end do jews have
any right to have any self-determination
in any piece
of their indigenous land or not and by
the way it's not
it's not to say that you know given that
like
little history that i just swept you
through the crusades and everything else
like is there a long-standing
palestinian connection to the land
and muslim connection to the land yes of
course there is is there a long-standing
christian connection
of course there is right the question is
only do we also acknowledge
that the jews have a connection to that
land or not and that to me is what
everything is about
is there room for an argument or a
debate where people say we completely
understand
israel's right to exist we support
israel's right to exist
but the expansive nature of a lot of the
policies
and maybe netanyahu himself as being
somebody who is uh you know has
certainly
uh put more of a right wing face on
uh policies and the bulldozing of the
settlements
and evicting people from their homes is
there a space for people to
argue like listen we think israel should
exist
but you know as a as a expert because
when you say colonial
power i think part of what gives that
argument credence in people's minds
is that the borders of israel don't seem
to be fixed they constantly seem to keep
expanding
and israel keeps evicting people from
their homes and
there there there is that that is
what most people regard as a colonial
um you know posturing from israel it's
not like
okay here are the borders and we're done
and i'm sure it's you know there's some
complexities there
but that's why pe like you said people
are saying
israel is a colonial state but it seems
like they're
that they're not finished like the
borders aren't uh
you know rock solid that they're
expanding and taking
more and more territory and some people
fear that they're taking
they want all the territory right so is
there a space to criticize bibi
netanyahu
100 i'll do it right now i did it often
in the pages of the new york times
is there a place to oppose settlements
and settlement expansion in the west
bank
of course i oppose them i do that all
the time what what this is
about again is fundamental existence and
let me just give you an example of that
in 2005
israel pulled out every single jew every
single israeli that lived in the gaza
strip
every single one left all of the
infrastruct the hot houses behind etc
what happens then it's not that there is
a
flourishing you know singapore uh on
in the gaza strip could have been
possible tons of money flowed into gaza
instead what there is is a
piece of land in proxima and rocket
proximity to the center of israel
run by a group that says in its charter
that their goal is not two states that
their goal
is to exterminate every single jew this
is from their charter
there is no solution to the palestinian
question except through jihad
the day of judgment will not come about
until the muslims fight jews and kill
them
then the jews will hide behind the rocks
and trees and the rocks and trees will
cry out oh muslim
there's a jew hiding behind me come and
kill them that's not just in the
founding it's also in these
videos that i pulled for you that i
don't think many people
see so maybe we want to play the one
about with the
hamas senior official talking about
we'll do that now and we'll we'll add
that in pose
and then there's a second video where
the mother
of uh palestinian martyr as
as they would call him talks about the
jews and says may their hearts be ripped
out
may their eyes be gouged out
allah
so that is what happened when israel
pulled out of the gaza strip
now you have the situation where israel
is occupying the west bank
and it's a horrible situation and i
oppose it the problem is is that
just from a purely like
existential perspective given what
happened when israel pulled out of the
gaza strip
there is an understandable fear and if
you want to understand why so many
israelis feel torn about this
their fear is okay what happens if we
pull out of the west bank
and there is another hamas terrorist
statelet
at our other border and the mid point of
israel
is like a mile wide that's an
existential problem and so
you have a tension where obviously
continuing to occupy another
people that you know like i believe
in a two-state solution i believe in the
palestinian right to self-determination
just as i believe in the jewish one
period but you have to understand
where that fear is coming from and why
israel doesn't just
unilaterally pull out of the west bank
as they did in gaza
you know 15 years ago right